hello good morning this is sky news
breakfast live from both sides of the
poland ukraine border as the
humanitarian crisis
the russians
visit
western ukraine from here tens of
thousands of people have boarded trains
to flee this country
and they are coming to places like this
crescenco in poland when they arrive as
refugees looking for sanctuary
a seventh night of violence in ukraine
with latest reports suggesting 21 people
have been killed and more than 100
injured in shelling in the eastern city
of kharkiv
president biden praises the bravery of
ukrainians
and unity of the west in the face of
vladimir putin's invasion
when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving
ukraine's president zielinski remains in
the capital kiev
telling reporters he's not seen his
family for several days while he defends
his country
edging slowly closer a huge convoy of
russian armored vehicles is now just 18
miles from the center of kiev
the ukrainian sports stars including the
world heavyweight boxing champion take
up arms to defend their country
[Music]
hello good morning we're live in
kraschenko in poland this is one of the
eight border crossing points with
ukraine and over the past week or so
this country has seen 450 000 people
forced from their homes in ukraine
seeking safety here as refugees from the
russian invasion
overnight president
to say that vladimir putin must pay a
price for his onslaught on ukraine as he
closed u.s airspace to russian aircraft
well let's take you through the latest
developments and in the last hour a
ukrainian official has said that at
least 21 people in kharkiv have been
killed in shelling in the last 24 hours
another 112 people were reportedly
wounded
late last night in zosmere a city about
85 miles west of kiev four people were
killed when a cruise missile hit their
homes
ukrainian forces still hold the cities
of kharkiv kersen and mario paul but
local ukrainian media reports that mario
paul's mayor says russian forces
captured the city's railway station and
port last night
well the huge russian convoy of tanks
and armor is now within 20 miles of the
city centre of kiev but has not made
significant progress since yesterday
the aftermath of a russian cruise
missile strike in jutomium a city 85
miles west of kiev and these are
residential buildings near a hospital
guys there's a man in this house be
careful the firefighter shouts
ukraine's 95th air assault brigade are
based in jutomia the russians were
likely aiming at them an interior
ministry official says four people were
killed
ukraine's wartime president unshaven and
tired looking as he spoke to reporters
no
i can't
when was the last time you saw them
before this war
thank you
i mean just one last question you may
vote no not before this war no three
days ago
the middle part of this war
yeah then the news that what the
russians had built is a precision strike
on ukrainian communication networks
right by the kiev tv tower has hit the
babinya holocaust memorial site
now it's bombing papilla yes the
memorial yes the memorial which that we
made they started building after
uh 80 years of this tragedy
it's second baby that is russia my
congratulations
thank you thank you guys thank you
russia is picking up the tempo of its
war on its next-door neighbor
eleven people were killed and apartment
buildings ripped to shreds in the
eastern city of kharkiv after a barrage
of artillery strikes on tuesday
including this strike on the main
government building in kharkiv's freedom
square early in the morning
this is a maternity ward in the southern
city of kersen forced to relocate to a
bomb shelter because the sick and those
about to give birth just can't leave
alongside the half a million who already
have ukraine's health minister posted
this picture on his facebook page of a
health worker he says was shot dead by
russian forces as she drove her injured
nephew to hospital in kiev
to the north of the city the 40-mile
long armored convoy bearing down seems
to have stalled a u.s official says it
may have logistical issues or fuel
shortages
the key of waits for the storm that is
to come one week into this war that
russia's president swore he would never
wage
[Music]
and we can talk to diana in moscow now
and diana has there been any response
from president putin to the latest
comments we've had from america
overnight
no not yet he doesn't tend to start
talking early
but we can expect some response from
the kremlin spokesman when he has his
daily call and i expect them to be
typically pugnacious
and belligerent because i think that is
the mood that vladimir putin is in now
as far as more developments overnight in
ukraine go we understand that russian
paratroopers have been having a an
extensive gun battle in kharkiv around
the military hospital there
but no loss of life um amongst the
ukrainian military but we do understand
that 21 have been killed in kharkiv over
the last few days
and as we saw in that report
no not much movement
of the convoy which is approaching to
kiev and a fairly quiet night in the
capital but if you think about the fact
that vladimir putin has bombed in his
first strikes in the center of kiev the
cemetery of babinya which is a holocaust
memorial to the tens of thousands who
were killed by the nazis uh uh during
world war ii and that vladimir zelensky
is jewish and that his family members
were killed by the nazis and vladimir
putin calls this a de-nazification
program essentially in ukraine it is it
just beggars belief the justification
that he is trying to sell to his own
people about this because what we're
seeing in ukraine is a terrible war and
what we're beginning to experience here
is an economic war that is going to be
incredibly long lasting
longer lasting than the conflict in
ukraine which joe biden said last night
would probably uh end up lasting quite a
long time in itself but here we're
already seeing a lot of people leaving
one businessman said to me vladimir
putin has undone the work of the last 20
years
and if you look back at the 90s at least
we had something to hope for and now we
don't a lot of people saying things like
who would want to live in north korea
but that's the people who understand the
impact of the economic sanctions and
what they will mean for
the future of the russian people and but
a lot of people don't because they
listen to the state's propaganda and
they don't understand what is happening
in ukraine
okay diana thanks so much for that
well let's look at the latest now
assessment from the uk defense secretary
ben wallace who joins me now um
mr wallace what power do you think the
west has to stop
what president putin is doing without
starting world war three
well we can uh help support which we
have done in the united kingdom has been
in the lead
the ability for ukrainian armed forces
and indeed the whole population to
defend itself that's why we have
equipped actually from a british point
of view for some months the ukrainians
with anti-tank missiles and other
weapons systems and non-lethal aid and
that's why last week last friday i
hosted a donor conference
off nearly 30 countries from nato and
non-nato to try and collect up as much
lethal aid and non-lethal as possible to
make sure they can do that so that's the
first thing i think the second thing is
as you've seen across the international
community very very strong uh raft of
sanctions you know we have seen
sanctions that i haven't seen before the
russian central bank has been sanctioned
a number of russian banks with their
assets have been frozen
you know that is going to cost the
russian government and the kremlin a lot
and it's going to reflect into the
economy of russia almost immediately i
think we saw 20 30 of the ruble's value
drop we saw interest rates nearly double
so the international community has shown
how very angry it is with what's going
on ukraine both economically
and from many us in europe the sort of
military point of view
and i think you know those two things
are one of the reasons why we see the
russian armed forces
moving very slowly
on its objectives it is behind schedule
considerably and while we've seen some
footage today in kakov of of russian
forces potentially in the middle of the
city they don't hold the city it's a
city of 1.4 million people
and they are taking casualties the
russians
and they're finding it very slow going
let's we'll go back to to what we know
about actually what's happening on the
ground um in a moment but first you
mentioned sanctions do you not think the
president putin will have factored in
that there would have been sanctions
that these sanctions would have been
enormous and that he actually doesn't
care about russia being a pariah state
well i think firstly i think he probably
looked at the sanctions the west put in
place in 2014 and calculated with his
large cash reserves that he would be
able to survive that type of repeat and
while some of those sanctions even 2014
still exist i think he probably planned
on them being raptured up i don't think
he would have woken up uh earlier you
know a few days ago and realized and
recognized that actually the swift
system did manage to kick russia out and
has taken the decision to sanction its
central bank i think that would have
been way beyond the expectations of the
russian system
but i think on your last point you know
i think what we have to remember here is
president putin believes that these
people would welcome him as a liberator
he was convinced in his own mind in his
own writings
that the russians and the ukrainians
were the same peoples and all they were
waiting for is the great czars or the or
the president of russia to come and
liberate them and of course when you
make that assumption you make all the
decisions that we see playing out
on our television screens which is a
sort of arrogant armed forces that has
got bogged down ill-prepared young
junior soldiers because the officers
just thought this was going to be much
easier than it was you see equipment in
the wrong places
and i think that's why
he is you know carrying on as he does
but your very last bit about does he
care well he obviously doesn't really
care i mean when i went to russia myself
the russian ministry of defense they
were very clear that russian people
could suffer greater than mine or
greater than europeans we can't be
harmed by sanctions and i remember
saying at one stage i actually don't
want russian people to suffer any more
than i want european and british people
to suffer that's my view i don't none of
us should want that but
i think there's definitely a sense of
pride that somehow russian suffering
equals russian
leadership and i think he's about to be
shocked because this is the 21st century
and russian people just like european
people don't want to go through what
they're about to go through
in terms of what is happening on the
ground do you have any understanding or
any information about why this convoy
approaching kiev appears to have stalled
is it do we think logistical issues
fueling for example or you know getting
getting supplies to them
or is it possibly a tactical thing to
wait
well i think it's a combination of all
of what you above effectively that what
we have seen is that
they weren't properly their tactics
weren't correct they were
doing things you know thought they they
were rather confident they would take
many of these cities in a few hours
rather than six days or longer
and when any army on the move uh has to
do takes longer to do things your
logistical supply chain is stretched you
know if you if you're given enough
rations for two days and it takes you
six you've suddenly got a problem and i
think what we've seen is
a lot of those issues are coming to bear
they've also been surprised by the
ukrainian strength of the resistance
and indeed as a result you know the
ukrainians have been also carrying out a
very clever plan we've seen footage we
can't verify but we've seen footage of
you know ukrainians using uavs to attack
petrol uh train convoys to go after
logistical lines we've seen railway
lines blown up
all the things that you and i you know
think of about when it comes to
resistance so i think
that is effectively coming home to roost
but it is also a switch in russian
tactics i think the russians have
realized that ukrainians by fighting are
costing them lots and lots of casualties
and the russians have taken significant
casualties uh far more than they would
have planned
and i think what they are therefore
doing is trying to switch tactics and
what you're seeing now is those heavy
bombardments at night uh they'll they'll
try they won't come into the cities as
much they will
i'm afraid as we've seen tragically
while the looks of things carpet bomb
cities uh indiscriminately in some cases
they will fly their air at night rather
than daytime because what we've seen is
they get shot down in the daytime
and they will try slowly but surely try
and surround the cities and then either
bypass them or bombard them and i think
you know that is the brutality that i'm
afraid we are witnessing and it's going
to get worse
i've worn before in your program that
that is you know the russian doctrine is
to get harder and tougher and more
indiscriminate
and that's why you know that tragic
strike on obviously the cemetery in the
in the center of kiev
is exactly what we should expect more of
some people believe you know you talk
about carpet bomb and cluster munitions
have been used thermobaric weapons have
been used are you confident that both
have
we will collect the evidence on on a
range of those
usage a number of international partners
such as canada are
quite rightly putting lots of effort in
collecting evidence if there was any
evidence of war crimes that would be
either presented to the international
criminal court or indeed countries on
their own are free to take certain
actions uh you know we have to you know
war crimes or anything else are done
based on evidence we've seen reports
we've certainly seen the deployment of
some of those weapon systems uh we
haven't verified the use uh but that's
what we will collect evidence for it and
um you know some of these weapons
systems are horrendous uh about a week
ago we summoned the defense attache from
the russian embassy to the ministry to
remind him of his obligations under the
geneva convention the geneva convention
is there to uphold a humanitarian
treatment of both prisoners of war but
also of civilian populations they have
to live up to those obligations and we
will make sure that we hold them to
account whatever happens whether it's
now or in years to come
boris johnson was held to account
personally yesterday by a ukrainian
journalist who wanted him to explain to
her why britain can't enforce a no-fly
zone over ukraine
why can't we
well i've been on your program about
four times the last week and i've
explained why
the reason is i'm afraid
simple
but
it is you know very difficult to take
that course but it is the course we have
to take which is
if you have a no-fly zone you have to
enforce a no-fly zone that would involve
british fighter jets shooting down
russian fighter jets
probably over ukraine that would lead to
article 5 triggering of nato and nato is
a self-defense pact all 30 countries
will come to each other's aid the
triggering of that article 5 would lead
to a war against russia across the whole
of europe that is not a position that
members of nato are prepared to go
that is
why one of the reasons you know russia
does not want countries to join nato
because once they are in nato this
self-defense mechanism is strong it's
why we're reinforcing and indeed
reassuring our friends in places like
the baltic states who are in nato but
are on the edge of russia but that is
the reality of it and we can do the next
best thing and that's not a great
comfort i understand to ukraine but we
can arm them we can support them uh we
can use bring convene the international
community to condemn russia to put in
very large sanctions to freeze their
assets to target the leaders
of that
country and you know whatever happens in
ukraine and i hope russia sees sense i
hope it realizes this is not a way
forward
but whatever happens in ukraine you know
the russian government we see before us
today on our television screens will be
isolated
and you know as i think one of your as
diana said in moscow uh you know
russians were saying we don't want to be
north korea but you know if they're not
careful
the the
long-term effect on the russian
government will be isolation
but it seems to me you know as i stand
here on the ukrainian border and watch
these families coming across i saw a
family three generations coming across a
short time ago the grandmother in tears
your you know reminding us all how
britain must play by the rules
but putin isn't playing by the rules how
far does he have to go in breaking the
rules before we take some kind of direct
action well i think the question is how
far does europe want us to get towards a
war across europe um with russia how far
does the british public uh want us to go
in
against a nuclear armed power uh who
may view escalation of all means so i
think we have to be realistic here
ukraine and i've said it even before
this conflict started
britain is at the forefront of helping
try and get ukraine into nato it takes
all 30 countries to support it we've had
troops in ukraine
through operation orbital since 2014
2015 helping the ukrainian train we've
trained 20 000 troops to get them up to
standard to join nato we've done a lot
of that but others wanted to move at a
different pace so the reality is on the
day that russia invaded ukraine a week
ago
ukraine was not in nato so we have to do
everything else in our power to do that
but i'm afraid i'm not going to sit here
and say i'm going to put at risk the
rest of europe
by triggering a major potentially war
across the whole continent
is the uk able to send planes to allow
ukrainians to enforce the no-fly zone
themselves
well look there isn't a no-fly zone so
let's just be really clear here and and
the other thing that no one seems to
talk about in the no-fly zone is who
does the no-fly zone benefit if you had
a no-fly zone in ukraine the
overwhelming scale of the russian army
would be able to drive around with
impunity which it can't at the moment
you talked about the armored column
without any air attack from the
ukrainians because there would be a
no-fly zone
so it's a bit like in 19 you know the
battle of britain if we said oh let's
have a no-fly zone you know an unhelpful
suggestion came around saying let's not
have a no let's have a no-fly zone that
would have suited the vast you know
german they're marked army uh we
wouldn't have suited the small uh you
know the united kingdom who were just
not far not previously just returned
back from dunkirk so so you know it
let's let's ask ourselves what would it
have achieved you can still have
fighting with a no-fly zone it just
won't be in the air and that would allow
those russian armored columns to drive
around with impunity
and not be struck from the air where
currently
ukrainian aircraft and ukrainian
unmanned air vehicles are causing damage
on key parts of their logistical chain
so i think we should people who suggest
a no-fly zone should be really clear
what they're trying to achieve and how
it would be enforced because i don't see
them actually
coming up with any logical details
behind it
okay ben wallace defense secretary thank
you very much for joining us this
morning
well let's see how the situation in
ukraine has developed in the last day
late last night at least four people
were killed when a russian airstrike hit
a residential area in zitima a city
around 85 miles west of kiev
in the second city kharkiv a missile
strike hit a regional administration
building in the central freedom square
yesterday morning
and in the last few minutes kharkiv's
governor has said at least 21 people
were killed and 112 wounded in that
shoving
in the capital kiev an airstrike on the
city's main tv tower yesterday afternoon
left at least five dead and took some
ukrainian channels off air briefly
president zielinski's office said that
the nearby holocaust memorial as we were
talking about was also damaged by a
strike
british intelligence suggests russian
forces are also encircling kirsten and
mario paul in the south
mario paul's mayor says 128 people are
currently in hospital following the
attacks in the city
kirsten's mayor has said that russian
forces had captured the city's railway
station and port last night
and overnight ukraine's defense ministry
has claimed it has evidence that belarus
is preparing to send its troops into the
country
satellite images in recent days have
shown belarusian aircraft assembling
near the border
the humanitarian situation crisis
continues to grow following russia's
invasion hundreds of thousands of people
have already left ukraine the united
states says that as of 1pm yesterday
over 660 000 people fled ukraine to
neighboring countries in the first six
days of the conflict
poland's deputy interior minister says
that the small
over 450 000 people had entered from
ukraine in total the un is estimated
that up to four million people could try
to flee the country and they are coming
across the north border here across
chenko they're being met by volunteers
who have uh fires going there's hot
drinks there's food for them
coming
uh to this border from poland to ferry
these people to refugee centers further
in land
so that's what's happening on the polish
side of the border let's get the latest
from inside ukraine adam parson joins us
now from the western city of levith
which has been a focal point for the
humanitarian crisis with tens of
thousands of people heading there before
they then head on towards the border
with poland and adam what is the
situation there this morning
the situation is busy and cold frankly
that building you can see behind me a
very grand building
uh is levi's main railway station so my
team and i came into here yesterday
afternoon from very near where you are
on a train that was very quiet about 60
people on it
when we got into that train station
quite curious actually the platforms
were deserted then you came down
into the the tunnels underneath and it
was packed with women and children who
were waiting to get on the train going
out of here and back
towards the polish border women children
and some
older people and pensioners i didn't see
any
young ukrainian men uh trying to get
onto that train there were foreign
foreign nationals students or migrant
workers the young ukrainian men are
staying here in ukraine they've been
asked to stay and fight for their
country and that is what they are doing
so the people you see
over there in the distance outside the
train station are the ones who are here
now trying to get
out of the country or arriving i think
it is worth saying
not everyone
is trying to flee ukraine and get uh
into poland
a lot of people who are arriving here in
lev and then remain here they are
displaced within their own country
arriving from whether it's here
i'm trying to get to a safer city which
lev is
at the moment but then again clearly
there are lots trying to flee the polish
border guard says 98 000 people crossed
into poland from ukraine yesterday they
say the total and this is just going to
poland is now about
450 000. let's paint you a little bit of
a picture of what it's like here it's
cold uh it's snowing and if you look
around here you see people who have
arrived with
with bags with with not many possessions
and they've arrived into a country
into an area city that is that is cold
uh
but welcoming the the welcome
comes in the form of uh
of food and and drink
and frankly
safety
and there's a slightly heady
sense to the air as well because
there's snow fluttering down on us
there's also
over there you can maybe i'll see the
smoke coming up these are from the from
the brazier from the the wood that is
being burnt on these enormous
charcoal uh ovens uh and so you have
that that smell in the air as well but
all around us are people who who need
help
uh come here with i can see this this
lady here is he's looking looking cold
and i'd say looking very very anxious
and scared
people don't have very much
they have
gone away from their homes and brought
very in many cases brought their their
pets with them you see a lot of of cats
and dogs
red cross is operating here i think
it is worth also saying that in la viv
itself
this is a safe place this is a long way
from the front line at the moment but
there's still that sense of nervousness
to get here we have had to come through
road blocks we had three people came
into our vehicle to check our
credentials one of them a a young man
very friendly man but holding a an ak-47
rifle i don't think he'd been he was
used to to having uh that to him
the we've seen an army recruitment
center with a line of people outside it
already there was a even bigger queue
we saw there yesterday there are these
kind of homemade anti-tank hedgehogs
enormous
metal devices
that are being put in place so we're a
long way from the fighting here and yet
the rumors always abound that the
belarusian troops could uh could descend
on this city
bottom line is this is where people are
trying to get away from lev
has become every ukrainian's plan b
adam thanks very much and and that is
their plan b and then i suppose this is
their plan c this is where they come to
when they've passed through lev they're
coming to border crossings like this
kroshenko as we've been talking to you
another family have come across the
border it's a really slow process
they're processing uh family groups
individually so about every sort of five
minutes another group come through
they're usually escorted by
the border guards wearing those black
outfits with the um with the yellow
marks on them
then they try and link them up with
somebody here on this side sometimes
they've got people they know and they're
being met by people and they're waiting
here there are cars parked further up
the hill but often it's just actual um
volunteers from poland you've come down
here to help take people to other parts
of the country they're taken from here
on to other areas onto central railway
stations and refugee centres where they
can stay overnight if they need to well
uh in the last few moments we've heard
um from the ukrainian president he says
that up so far by day six of the
conflict six thousand russian troops he
believes have been killed in this
conflict and he's renewed his bid for
ukraine to join the eu
meanwhile president biden has used his
state of the union address to say that
russia is now more isolated from the
world than ever he said vladimir putin
will pay a high price for invading
ukraine our u.s correspondent mark stone
reports from washington
president biden has vladimir putin
committed war crimes
no comment from the american president
as he left the white house for the short
journey up pennsylvania avenue
they had gathered on capitol hill for
the key annual moment in america's
political diary but the state of the
union this year required a broader focus
madam
with the yellow and the blue dotted
through the chamber he pitted autocracy
against democracy good against evil
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead he met with a mall a wall of
strength he never anticipated or
imagined he met the ukrainian people
in the audience the guest of honor
ukrainian ambassador of the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady
let each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
unity among nations was the key theme
in the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising to the moment and
the world is clearly choosing the side
of peace and security it was this
message for those who surround putin
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it and as he has so many times he
said again america would not fight in
ukraine would not fight russia but would
defend freedom however it can it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
but at a time when american and western
resolve is facing its greatest challenge
in decades there were no standout sound
bites no george bush axis of evil
moments no this was measured calm
focused and yet it couldn't provide any
hints of how all this might develop how
it might end
as he left the president had a message
of support for his top generals
a man whose counsel he values and may
need in the weeks ahead mark stone sky
news in washington
well while the diplomacy and the
statements come from world leaders of
course the fighting is still going on
inside ukraine where many many millions
of people still are alex rossi joins us
now from inside from dinipro
what is the situation where you are
well at the moment it's extremely tense
it's calm with inside the city of
dinipro this is a
an arterial city which links east and
west so it would be a key strategic
target for the russians uh the
assumption really is that they will push
up from the south and in from the east
once they've taken uh the areas there
now in terms of the russian fighting
along the coastline with the sea of azov
ukraine has pretty much
now been cut off uh from that coastal
area
mariopol another key city is from what i
understand
uh pretty much surrounded now by russian
forces there's been fairly heavy
bombardments uh shelling inside the city
in residential areas
the situation there is pretty desperate
as it is
in ukraine's second city of kharkiv
which again has faced a pretty heavy
pounding overnight they've also been
reports from the ukrainian authorities
that russian uh paratroopers arrived at
about 3 a.m and there were significant
and very prolonged clashes in the city
and of course that place is also being
hit hard by shelling as well the fear is
in all of these areas that russia
perhaps frustrated by the problems that
it has had so far in this invasion is
now really upping the violence as far as
the ukrainians are concerned
they are accusing the russians and there
is plenty of evidence of that as well
which we can independently verify that
they are attacking civilian areas with
the intent of terrorizing
the population and that appears also to
be working we are seeing very large
numbers of people now fleeing the
country the united nations says
something around something like 660 000
people have now fled train stations are
crowded people are squeezing on to
whatever transport they can get on so
that they can get out of the country but
that's not to say that the resistance
against the russian invasion remains as
fierce as ever all over this city and
it's something that's replicated across
ukraine um they are digging in for a
prolonged and sustained uh fight they
will keep resisting the russians and try
to repel
those forces for as long as they can
effectively what you have here and this
perhaps is a reflection
of why it is so very desperate is this
is an existential fight really for the
soul of ukraine as far as the ukrainians
our concerns they talk about freedom
they talk about democracy they don't
want the cloak of darkness of the the
kremlin uh descending across their
country and they are going to to pay for
that
uh in blood and sweat they say they will
continue fighting
for as long as they can
alex thanks very much for that
well a short while ago uh i spoke to the
defense secretary ben wallace and he
told me that russia's apparent slow
progress may in part be down to the
assumption of vladimir putin the troops
would have been welcomed by ukrainians
and the invasion would not have been met
with such strong resistance
what we have to remember here is
president putin believes that these
people would welcome him as a liberator
he was convinced in his own mind in his
own writings
that the russians and the ukrainians
were the same peoples and all they were
waiting for is the great czars or the or
the president of russia to come and
liberate them and of course when you
make that assumption you make all the
decisions that we see playing out
on our television screens which is a
sort of arrogant armed forces that has
got bogged down ill-prepared young
junior soldiers because the officers
just thought this was going to be much
easier than it was you see equipment in
the wrong places
and i think that's why
he is you know carrying on as he does
well it's getting really busy down here
now on the border this morning a bit of
a change
of troops as as it were in terms of
staffing here um and also quite a lot of
lorries bringing supplies etc down here
um let's talk to tamara cohen now who
joins us now from from westminster in
terms of the politics tomorrow um we've
got prime minister's questions today of
course
what pressure do you think will be
brought uh upon the prime minister about
the current situation
morning jane well i think what's not
going to be the subject of pressure on
the prime minister really is to
introduce a no-fly zone there aren't
significant calls from conservative or
labour mps to do that for the reasons
that ben wallace set out very bluntly
there perhaps more bluntly than the
prime minister did yesterday that it
risks simply a nuclear war because
russia is a nuclear-armed country and as
ben wallace put it they may escalate
this conflict by any means if um if nato
forces go out trying to enforce such a
no-fly zone and he also says that those
who were advocating it and have not
thought through the fact that it may
actually disadvantage the ukrainians
militarily and benefit the russians so
very firmly slapping down that idea the
help that we're going to be offering to
the ukrainians he made very clear his
sanctions and he said that these
sanctions are above and beyond what
vladimir putin would have facted into
his calculations really biting on
ordinary russians and of course sending
military aid as we have done already and
maybe doing at the moment to the
ukrainians to try and fight the russians
he was he talked about the role of
morale and the fact that the ukrainian
resistance has been so fierce is perhaps
the reason why this convoy
of tanks that we can see in those
satellite pictures making its way
towards kiev has made such slow progress
he says the russians may be in pro
process of changing their strategy to
bombarding cities that's going to be
terrible news for all those ukrainians
hold up in cities that this may be a
very long war there may be a very long
resistance to be fought there but he was
very clear that the the military aid
that nato will be providing is is at its
full extent at the moment i think the
questions the prime minister will face
today are about refugees and whether the
government will allow it any more they
announced yesterday that an extended
family of ukrainians living in the uk
would be allowed to apply to come here
but nothing at the moment for ukrainians
who don't have ties here and there may
be also calls from labour for those
sanctions to be sped up
okay tomorrow thanks very much as we've
been talking to tomorrow another family
have just come through and been
processed and gone into a private car
to go back
into poland and let's get some more
reaction though from another country in
eastern europe let's talk to the prime
minister of kosovo albin kirti really
good to talk to you today sir thanks a
lot for joining us on sky news
how concerned are you that the events
that are happening in ukraine could
spill over into the balkans possibly uh
into your country
uh good morning well
i
think that we've already seen this in
the balkans
in kosova in spring 1999 when 860 000
albanians from kosovo were deported to
albania montenegro and north macedonia
hundreds of massacres took place 12 000
civilians
have been killed unarmed civilians and
at the same time
20 000 women have been raped we see now
this russian invasion military
aggression that every institutional
leader every european and world
politician should condemn fiercely
clearly
and
in this way we should all show
solidarity and admiration with the
courage and liberation struggle of
ukrainian people
balkans is not immune from the effects
of the situation in ukraine
because in the balkans we have a country
which did not impose sanctions on
russian federation which did not join eu
into condemning russian invasion and
that is serbia our first neighbor
we have a very long border with serbia
serbia is our
northern neighbor who does not recognize
republic of kosova
in contrast to albania montenegro and
north macedonia they have very strong
ties and these ties are both cultural
and historical on one hand
but also military and economic ones
for ex for example serbia has 14 mig-29
and they
these fighter jets and they've gotten
eight of them as donation from belarus
and six from russian federation
in serbian parliament out of 250 mps
151 of them
are members of the russian serbian
friendship group it is the larger
friendship group
and uh at the same time gazprom
russian gazprom owns 56
of oil industry in serbia and 51 percent
of gas storage
in uh
banana which is the biggest one in
southern eastern europe luke oil spare
bank all
russian
companies have their branches in serbia
and that's why uh people of kosova are
worried
that uh
despotic president of russian federation
vladimir putin will try to
outsource
war also in the western balkans by
turning it into his uh
battleground with western democracies
but we stand firm
and vigilant and we are not afraid
we want to join eu and nato
currently we have nato in kosova but
sooner we get nato membership it will be
better for
people of kosova for republic of kosova
but for the entire
region and
european continent in general
and and kosovo kosovo has already been
mentioned hasn't it by the russian
foreign minister a few times he said
that people from kosovo had gone to
fight at donbass
what do you make of that
that shows his intention he wants to
destabilize the balkans that's why he's
saying these false things
there are no
kosovar citizens who went to fight in
donbass
it is russia which annexed donbass and
crimea
let us not forget that
president putin came to power as prime
minister of russian federation
uh only two months after liberation of
kosovo in 1999
and then he annexed south ossetia and
aposia in georgia in the same year few
months after we declared our
independence on 17th of february 2008.
president putin was mentioning kosova at
least once a month and now he's doing it
every week
because
he simply hates nato hates the west
he is a despotic leader who is both
bitter and nostalgic
and he would like to
turn hybrid war into war
now we have seen that hybrid war was
never a substitution for war it was just
its preparatory phase
and there is hybrid war also in the
western balkans
and sputnik center is in belgrade for
the entire region of western balkans
that's why eu and nato
should engage more with the western
balkans
i urge five non-recognizers within eu to
recognize republic of kosovo spain
slovakia romania greece and cyprus
should recognize independence of kosova
and in this way contributes a great deal
to
peace stability and
security on the other hand
president putin
was receiving was hosting at sochi
last november president of serbia vuchic
who during the meeting showed map of
kosova
with northern part in particular
because some of the illegal structures
of serbia are still very active and
functioning there
basically
they are in
close coordination
that's why
eu capitals
should be very firm in asking from
belgrade to condemn russian invasion and
military aggression because ukraine has
not been overrun by earthquake or
floods it was not a natural disaster
it was war machinery
led by a despotic president with a
genocidal intent which is causing a
mass expulsion of ukrainians from
ukraine apparently
russian blitzkrieg has failed
but it is obvious for me that they will
go now after a partition after dividing
ukraine into eastern and western part
where the western part they will try to
be landlocked and as small territorially
as uh possible that's why i uh
support people of ukraine
we have imposed sanctions on russian
federation just like council of eu
decided and at the same time we are
going to host 20 journalists from
ukraine who had to flee their country
last sunday
the decision of bundestag was historic
and uh that was of of a great uh help
for uh eu and for the region
okay we must leave it there uh prime
minister of kosovo alvin kersey really
good to talk to you today and thank you
so much for joining us thank you
thank you let's just bring you some new
images that we have um scotland news has
verified the video of a missile strike
in kharkiv the second largest city in
ukraine or the attack caused damage to
university and government building which
are opposite one another the two
buildings
are in the centre of kharkiv with this
strike of course following yesterday's
attack on the city's freedom square
well in his first state of the union
address the us president joe biden last
night vowed that vladimir putin would
not divide the west but how has the u.s
response to the crisis being received
well national security analyst and
attorney ari aramesh joins me now
from west london ari good to talk to you
today um what did you make of biden's
comments last night talking about a
closure of
u.s airspace to russian planes is it
going to make any difference to
president putin do you think
well it's going to increase the pressure
it's important to pressure president
putin both militarily uh economically
and also physically now russian air
space
or at least russian uh airplanes and
equipment and aircraft have have now
been uh have now become unwelcome in
many uh european capitals and and now in
in in the united states uh and it's not
just uh
oligarchs it's not just that military
sort of exchanges but the most important
thing is these civilian aircrafts are no
longer welcome to come to the united
states now that that sends a message to
the russian people that the actions of
president putin has made
and has turned russia into a pariah for
years and years putin's clients like
harmony of iran were assad of
of of syria
they were the pariahs but they were
clients of moscow and now you see that
president putin and his inner circle and
now are now turning russia into one of
those international prior trials that
that
ironically have also brought such a
spirit of unity to the western world
into the free world last night watching
president biden's uh state of the union
address uh you could not have seen
bipartisan standing ovation
for president trump i'm sorry for
president biden just a couple weeks ago
but every time he mentioned ukraine
every time he talked about the ukrainian
people's solidarity ukraine ukrainian
people's
strong will uh to defend uh themselves
and to fight for their destiny and also
american support for ukrainians for nato
for the western alliance and for the
free world you saw bipartisan standing
ovation and long-standing ovations for
that matter so
yes putin has miscalculated he has
failed uh and now he's paying the price
but here's the thing i don't think putin
is going to just roll back his incursion
because we're imposing sanctions
sanctions are a punishment but there are
long-term punishment right now what the
ukrainians need the most especially
coming from those nato borders from
hungary from slovakia from romania and
from poland are arms lethal arms lethal
defensive measures to be able to take
out russian armor and russian mechanized
units and russian infantry the javelin
missiles stingers to take out and
neutralize russian air superiority so
yes that we should continue
uh helping the ukrainian people with
with aid we should continue helping the
ukrainian government both rhetorically
but also finance this war effort and
sent what they need and that is arms and
that especially armor busting javelins
that is exactly the sort of equipment
they need and we should we should
provide it now again even if major
cities were to fall even if key or
harkief or mario paul in the east odessa
in the south even if they were to fall
you could still have an insurgency on
your hand and that could still exert
much cost and much pressure on putin and
on a russian sort of occupying force in
ukraine so
helping out the ukrainian resistance
ukrainian military and the ukrainian
people in this phase even if
major cities were to fall still not
futile it's a long-term investment in
this fight
irish aramis national
security analyst and attorney good to
talk to you thank you very much
well russian's invasion of ukraine has
brought about a raft of changes to
global flight patterns of course
let's talk now to ryanair chief
executive michael o'leary um mr o'leary
um
in terms of flights to this part of the
world uh what has the impact been
obviously you're not able to fly into
ukraine anymore but but has there been a
knock on impact on other areas around
here
not really jane uh we were ukrainian's
largest airline we flew to the four
airports in ukraine up until last
thursday morning kiev kharkiv odessa and
levive
we carry about 2 million passengers a
year to and from the ukraine but all
those aircraft are based in poland in
romania in italy and in germany so you
know regrettably while we'd like to
continue to serve the ukraine this the
skies are closed which is right i think
for safety reasons we'll pivot those
aircraft and operate more flights from
poland romania italy and germany to the
beaches of greece italy spain and
portugal this summer um
much as we we have seen obviously a huge
increase in demand for our flights to
and from those polish cities where uh
many ukrainians are now traveling back
to the uk and to other uh
cities where they have relatives across
europe uh our flights from
krakow warsaw and we're very happy to
play a very small role in reuniting
those ukrainian families across europe
how quickly could you turn things around
if the situation changed and it became
safer in ukraine how quickly could you
get planes back in there
uh we'd have planes back in there i
think within about four weeks but the
challenge is how much the airports have
been degraded uh last thursday night our
understanding was that the the russians
took out the the radar uh facilities at
the ils and the radars at the main uh
ukrainian airports which is why the
european authorities said it closed the
skies it wasn't safe to fly there but
subject and i think you know there'd be
a huge willingness on the from western
authorities to rebuild those radars to
put the facilities back in particularly
for the summer and i guarantee you rhino
will be the first aircraft be the first
airline and first aircraft back into
ukraine as soon as it opens we value our
business in ukraine as i said we have
two million ukrainian customers flying
with us every year
and we will restore that business as
soon as
it is safe to do so and as soon as we're
permitted to do so safely
and what about the of course the
knock-on impact we've seen on fuel
prices generally across the world what
impact is that having on the airline
industry and presumably those increases
are going to be passed on to passengers
i think it's going to be very difficult
for most airlines uh for the next 12
months i mean last thursday we saw spot
oil prices rise from you know 70 uh from
75 to over a hundred dollars a barrel
thankfully or luckily uh ryanair we're
80 percent hedged we've hedged out about
80 of our fuel needs out to march 2023
so for this summer and for the rest of
this year we'll still be able to pass on
low oil prices and low fares to our
customers because we have a very strong
fuel hedging position
up until last thursday we were hedging
into the summer of 2023 we've about nine
percent of our fuel needs bought forward
at about 75 dollars a bar but those
prices have now over the last five days
rocketed to 95 dollars a barrel
you know i and i'm not sure
we would still believe uh hopefully that
the ukrainian situation will be resolved
in favor of ukraine in the short near to
short term but there's no doubt that if
oil prices remain high at around 100 a
bar we are going to see a dramatic
increase in supply the iranians are
talking to the americans about resolving
the nuclear discussions they're already
loading up tankers to export oil the u.s
shale producers we believe will start
turning on production and i think the
most important thing we in the west can
do is drive up oil production because
what hits russia hardest is low oil
prices and low gas prices so
we should as well as sanctioning the
russians do everything we can to
increase oil and natural gas supplies
around the world drive down oil prices
because that's what hits the uh the
russian authorities uh
hardest is low oil prices
okay michael leary good to talk to you
this morning thanks a lot for joining us
on sky
well uh you're watching sky news uh live
from the polish ukrainian board this
morning we're at kroschenko this is one
of the the places that those wanting to
leave ukraine are coming to they're
arriving at the border on the other side
some on foot the majority are being
dropped off
by car we are seeing some cars come
through not so many but the ones that do
come through are absolutely full to the
gunnels of people they are really really
chock full as many people as possible
getting across some cars we're also
seeing a lot of families coming across
on foot mums and children being met by
people here on the polish side of the
border